at a time when we were waiting for an
AFC North team to engage in a
high-profile trade an AFC North team did
just not the Pittsburgh Steelers with
Antonio Brown it's the Baltimore Ravens
sending tentatively quarterback Joe
Flacco to the Denver Broncos now we know
this drill by now the deal can't be done
until the first day of the league year
that's March 13 and in theory the Ravens
could back out the Broncos could back
out but typically these deals do indeed
go through and when this deal goes
through the Broncos will have their
latest starting quarterback because
Flacco not getting paid 18 and a half
million dollars by the Broncos to sit on
the bench and the Broncos know what
Flacco can do go back to 2012 divisional
round of the playoffs special season for
the Broncos late in the game Broncos
ahead Joe Flacco throws the ball deep to
Jacoby Jones who scores the touchdown
ties the game the Broncos lose in double
overtime to the Ravens who go on to win
Super Bowl xlvii Flacco becomes the MVP
and parlays that into not one but two
major contracts with the Ravens also in
the first two years of Flacco's tenure
in Baltimore Vic Fangio was on the
Ravens staff Vic Fangio now the head
coach of the Denver Broncos and Fangio
has recently said that he's trying to
balance winning now versus winning later
Flacco is a Moore win now type of a
quarterback not necessarily a win later
guy unless they decide to keep him
around for three four five six years but
the bottom line is with the Broncos
having back-to-back losing seasons for
the first time since 1971 1972 they have
to find a way to break out of this and
having Joe flat go around in their
estimation will give them an opportunity
to get back on the right side of 500
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports